here we go we got more  hey what's up Ted in the net come on in  yes all right thanks for coming  have a bloody good time awesome oh oh  there he is what's up Noah Michael  Jackson  [Music]  that's Michael Jackson  [Music]  great  [Music]  you want to come inside  that's annoying that is very annoying  stop stop  don't do it anymore  just keep doing the Shimon that's where  the children  that's some bad taste  this isn't don't even know what that is  Thriller eyes  what are you doing Kevin Owens no you  cut off oh okay he doesn't slap his ass  like that so I don't know what okay  [Music]  hey stop stop it stop it stop it  the costumes awful the impression is  stupid and played out everybody and  their mother was Michael Jackson three  years ago when he died  you died  oh  wait wait wait he died oh Noah  oh no  what no wait wait a second don't stand  and walk away  happy Halloween